you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
contaminated with sewage slurry and
plastic a damning report by mp says only
14 of england's rivers are in a good
ecological state
the world's sixth warmest on record u.s
scientists say extreme weather events
from heat waves to floods are linked to
global warming
and the call for the world's biggest
companies to do more to tackle
deforestation
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
and we start with a worrying report on
england's waterways which has found that
the vast majority of rivers contain a
chemical cocktail of sewage slurry and
plastic the parliamentary environmental
audit committee says only 14 of the
country's rivers have a good ecological
status and that the water regulator
could do more to tackle the companies
responsible well in a moment i'll be
speaking to one of the members of that
committee but first here's fraser
moore's report
virtually all of england's rivers now
contain a chemical cocktail of sewage
slurry and plastic so says a damning
report by the environmental audit
committee into the state of our
waterways only 14
of english rivers meet good ecological
status and none of them can be given a
clean bill of health for chemical
contamination
frankly for the last 60 years because
our drainage and sewerage
systems are all underground out of sight
we've not invested in water treatment
to cope with the increased investment in
what's been happening above ground
the environment minister rebecca powell
says we are going further and faster
than any other government to protect and
enhance the health of our rivers and
seas we welcome the eac's report she
says which highlights many areas that
this government is now tackling you
don't have to look too far for evidence
of pollution here on the river tame
there are bits of plastic and debris
scattered all along the riverbanks but
it's not the plastic that you can see
that makes this one of the most polluted
rivers in england it's the plastic that
you can't
this microscopic image shows tiny
plastic beads and fragments collected
from the bed of the river tame the best
way to keep my clothes out of rivers is
to treat the wastewater
simple
professor jamie woodward collected the
mica plastics which he says can only
have come from untreated waste water if
wastewater is
released from wastewater treatment works
from sewage treatment works into river
systems under dry weather conditions
under low flows those microplastics will
accumulate on the channel bed and
they're often marinated in sewage
the report has over 80 recommendations
including better funding of the
environment agency stricter monitoring
of water companies and stronger
punishments for those who break the
rules
fraser moored sky news manchester
well joining me now is robert goodwill
who's part of the environmental audit
committee welcome to you so your
committee found that just 14
of rivers in england are high quality
it's pretty shocking isn't it how have
we got to this point
yeah it's very grim reading and indeed
much of the emphasis in the past has
been about bathing water quality so you
know in my constituency we've done a lot
to clean up the outfalls into the sea
but the rivers i think have been largely
ignored and there's multiple problems
we've talked about microplastics there's
problems with runners from agricultural
land but also we've seen a lot of
development which hasn't really been
kept up with by the water companies in
terms of sewage treatment the committee
went on to the river windrush in
oxfordshire and you know the water
looked like sort of one of those colors
in the farron ball catalogue there was
nothing in there it was dead
and we really need to catch up and
invest in better water treatment and
indeed as people nowadays seem to want
to maybe swimming in rivers a little
more we need to make sure we have safe
bathing water people swim in rivers as
well as the sea
what about investment in the environment
agency i mean your committee condemned
outdated underfunded and inadequate
monitoring of river quality how much
were budget cuts there responsible do
you think
well that has an effect on them but the
water companies themselves should be
testing uh and we you know we with much
better equipment now for testing in real
time and we indeed we have community
groups who are doing the testing for
them and i think they could the report
looks at how they can be engaged to
actually do more in terms of feeding in
that that information but
yes it's a pretty grim reading and and
really we need more investment we need
the opportunity for example we also
recommend that if water companies don't
perform then the bonuses some of the big
bonuses paid to pay to their executives
should be looked at as well so you know
i think it's about as hard-hitting as it
could be is this particular report well
how much difference do you think that
the government's environment bill will
make to protecting our rivers because
there are a number of environmental
campaigners there's also a number of
peers in the house of lords as well who
just say the bill's too lenient on water
companies
well i think we do need to realize that
this will take some time and and one of
the problems is storm water overflow so
when it's very heavy rain quite a lot of
um our country particularly the older
housing have combined outfall so you
know the rain water goes in the sewer
and that completely overflows and
inundates the sewage treatment work so
we do need more investment in stormwater
tanks so we can catch this stormwater
and then treat it later um but yeah i
think the the certainly the duke of
wellington's amendment i think was very
ambitious but i think it didn't take
into account the fact that it will be
the consumers uh who will pay for this
through their water bills and through
their sewage charges who need that
investment to be rolled out but we do
need better information more monitoring
and looking at for example the whole
issue of
microbial resistant a lot of these
pathogens going into the rivers that
when we have these overflows you know
can help build us sort of diseases that
people you know can't be treated with
conventional antibiotics to cure so you
have some very real issues and um and
also of course we've got the the problem
in towns of people putting you know fat
burgs putting the fat in the drain and
combined with wet wipes that's creates
those massive fat bugs some as big as a
blue whale uh so you know there's a lot
of res i think there's responsibility in
some cases on on people who are putting
things into the water system that they
shouldn't which does make the work of
the watered companies even harder
well sir robert goodwill we appreciate
your time thanks very much indeed for
joining us tonight
now last year was the sixth warmest year
on record contributing to extreme
weather events around the world these
include the dramatic heatwave in the
pacific northwest of america and
flooding across europe and china
according to experts at nasa and the
national oceanic and atmospheric
administration in america who put
together this research
well this animation shows analysis by
nasa's goddard institute for space
studies of the world's surface
temperature now it shows the anomaly in
global temperatures using the land ocean
temperature index or lotte against the
baseline average measured over 30 years
now that all sounds very technical but
what we can see clearly is that after
1970 the world has been warming up shown
by the increase in yellow and in recent
years several areas are actually quite
red which indicates three or more
degrees over their reference levels well
our u.s correspondent martha kelner
joins me now from washington so martha
yet another report showing just how warm
the world's becoming
yeah some very stark but perhaps not
unexpected findings from this report it
is as you mentioned a joint report by
two u.s government agencies nasa which
most people will have heard of and the
national oceanic and atmospheric
administration which measures the heat
of the world's oceans among other things
the report confirms what many people
would anecdotally suspect and that's
that the world is gradually warming and
it's causing increasing frequency of
these extreme
weather events it found last year as you
mentioned was ranked as the sixth
warmest on record and we've seen in our
reporting the impact of climate change
across the globe we've reported on this
side of the world from extreme heat
waves on the western side of canada and
the western states of the us we've
reported from california where entire
towns have been raised to the ground by
wildfires we've also seen the
devastating impact of flooding in
germany and other parts of europe and
also a series of hurricanes across the
atlantic and gavin schmidt the director
of nasa's institute for space studies
who were involved in this report said
their analysis added to evidence that
global warming is very real it's now and
it's impacting real people the report
also looked at so-called billion-dollar
weather events that's whether events
which have caused one billion dollars of
damage or more and it found that in 2021
uh that they've been the second highest
number of these so-called events
on on record you may remember hurricane
ida and the the devastating destruction
that caused across louisiana the tail
end of that hurricane even impacted new
york
and new jersey as well it found that
that had caused 75 billion or 55 billion
pounds worth of damage making that event
the most costly this year in the united
states
martha thanks very much
in some of today's other climate news
energy experts say the uk's gas grid
will be able to deliver a 20 blend of
hydrogen to households across the
country by next year energy networks
association the trade body of network
companies said using hydrogen is a
cleaner and more secure source of energy
which could significantly lower
household emissions currently around a
third of household emissions come from
heating
30 multinational companies are being
targeted by the same group of activists
who won a landmark court ruling against
shell last year friends of the earth
netherlands has asked the companies to
provide plans outlining how they'll cut
their emissions by 45
from 2019 levels by 2030. they've warned
that a failure to do so may result in
legal action
china has released a sustainability
report which outlines its efforts to
make the beijing winter olympics a low
carbon event
the report includes measures such as
reusing venues from the 2008 olympic
games and powering stadiums using
renewable electricity
critics have raised concerns over the
environmental cost of a games which will
rely on artificial ice and snow
now some of the world's biggest
companies and institutions are failing
to tackle deforestation despite a
commitment from 141 global leaders at
the cop 26 summit last november to halt
or reverse the practice destroying the
world's forest is a major contributor to
increasing carbon emissions causing
global warming and climate change so
here's a reminder of what some of those
leaders said back in glasgow
leaders have come together representing
over 85 percent of the world's forest
estate they've made a landmark
commitment to work together to halt and
reverse deforestation and land
degradation by 2030. not just halt but
reverse today i'm announcing
a new plan to conserve global forest
which will bring together a full range
of u.s government tools diplomatic
financial and policy this three billion
dollars in pledges will drive a new
three-fold nature agenda
there is um valuable future without the
tropical rainforest
frankly
we've all had enough talking so we need
to put our words into and commitments
into practice
well the annual forest 500 report of 350
companies and 150 financial institutions
finds that one-third of companies whose
activities are having most effect on
deforestation have no commitment to
reduce their impact 72 percent
have no commitment to tackle the problem
in their supply chains now just 26
percent of companies and 21 of financial
institutions recognize that
deforestation is a risk of their
business through its impact on climate
change water supply or biodiversity loss
these companies need to start with the
basics get a policy a trans clear and
transparent policy in place
so that groups like ours and the world
the companies that made these
commitments the governments can see that
companies in their jurisdictions are
taking this issue seriously they then
need to engage suppliers and set them
deadlines to improve traceability and to
take action on this issue and they need
to report transparently on their
progress no one should stay under the
radar and this is an issue that nobody
wants consumers don't want this and so
all of us as voters as pension holders
we need to keep the pressure up on our
banks our supermarkets and our
politicians
do stay tuned coming up next i'll be
joined by chidi oti obihara co-founder
of cop 26 action plan group and former
energy secretary amber rudd and we'll be
discussing the two biggest issues facing
the country today politics and energy
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with chidi
oti obihara co-founder of cop 26 action
plan group and former energy and climate
secretary amber radzo very good evening
to both of you good to see you both
now today we're going to discuss two of
the biggest issues facing the country
today which in turn are inextricably
linked to climate issues politics and
energy and uh amber rudd you're
perfectly placed to speak about both of
those first of all
all the controversy surrounding boris
johnson calls from some within the party
for him to step down you were a tory mp
for many years so what do you think
should he go
well the thing about boris johnson is
that what he surprised many of us about
is making addressing dangerous climate
change one of the top things in his
agenda
so he has been very pro particularly for
conservative government if i may say at
addressing climate change addressing the
the key subject that we've just seen
about deforestation and leading on
hosting cop26 so i find it very
disappointing um like many people do
shall i say to put a mild spin on it
that the conservative party is so
wrapped up again in its own internal
fighting about what should happen next
with boris johnson rather than getting
on with what we have in hand which is a
climate emergency some need for new
legislation and some new leadership on
this subject so does that mean you don't
want to call for him to go you don't
want to comment on it is that what
you're saying yeah anna it's not it's
not for me i'm no longer a politician
i'm sort of active in the private sector
now and trying to work with ngos like
the climate group to try and make sure
that we get the right policies in place
to address climate change but one thing
i would say is i haven't always been a
huge supporter of boris johnson's but he
has been clear about wanting to address
climate change and putting policies uh
which
for a conservative government have been
very very supportive of trying to do
that so i hope that they will last
whatever the outcome is okay so so
chilly what do you think um whether the
prime minister goes or not do you agree
that this is a distraction and if you
were to go what impact do you think that
could have on climate policies i mean
he's already under pressure isn't he
from some tory back benches over energy
price rises and the roll of green levees
in energy bills do you think his
departure would give those voices more
sway
it's not a viable thing to say uh to a
circle boris johnson is somehow the
great green conservative he's not he's
made several mistakes and the policy
positions he's set up have been
challenged now currently being
challenged in the courts my friends the
earth and client earth um the fact that
global oil and gas markets are in
turmoil has only amplified the fact that
the policy solutions the restaurants and
stuff to come up with are not viable
ones they don't work and they haven't
stuck to the core principles
behind many of the demands that the
people on the green end of the spectrum
have have made so we for example the
culturally sex production plan asked
that the uk government show a lead in
banning all new fossil fuel finance and
following that through
at cop26 in november in glasgow that
hasn't happened in an explicitly
complete way unless the world has
watched us stumble through this process
and now are watching us go through this
really
undignified process of of scrambling
through uh lockdown processes that we
set out we broke
it's disgrace so amber rudd let's pick
up on that that issue over investment in
oil and gas when you were an energy
secretary you were keen to push gas as a
transition fuel weren't you but we've
now seen soaring gas prices they're
behind a huge projected rise in people's
bills so was it a mistake
to promote gas
no and we need gas i mean the future in
the future
we will have renewable energy and i hope
batteries and possibly hydrogen so we
won't need as much if at all gas one day
in the future but right now we need gas
and we're seeing at the moment this huge
demand for gas and it is demand uh not i
mean chidi is quite wrong not so recent
policies that are affecting the price of
the gas that consumers are having to get
pay at the moment and again have to pay
even higher when the price cap
reflects that in april we gas is a
transition fuel we need it at the moment
and we should not go around saying that
we can stop it at a cliff edge most
people describe what we're going through
as a transition that means that we need
the gas in order to get to a place where
we can let go of the gas but that is
many many years ahead at the moment we
should be extracting gas and we should
do it in a way that is clean as possible
that is as efficient as possible but
hopefully will help build the energy
security not just of the uk but of
europe as well to be totally dependent
on russian gas would be such a mistake
okay we need a gas then chidi uh for the
transition to renewables but also for
energy security
amber is making a very classic mistake
asking for no new fossil fuel projects
is not the same thing as asking we turn
off the taps immediately
it's saying that investing in a stranded
asset
that adds the world's carbon footprint
is wrong
now i can't be wrong in saying that
because that's what the ipcc has told
the rest of the world that's what we've
signed up to in this country and 190
other countries around the world also
signed up to this we signed up to a
limit of 1.5 degree rises since
pre-industrial levels and it's true many
so-called green conservatives have
allowed this to simply slip list trust
for example set out a a trade deal with
the australians which removed deleted
excluded the 1.5 degree target and it's
that kind of thinking that allows people
like amber to turn around and say we can
carry on investing in new fossil fuel
projects we can't it's wrong
okay so no new oil and gas projects
amber would you back that
well i mean if you think about it would
you rather have uh would you rather be
buying in russian gas because we're
still using gas or would you rather have
gas from the north sea
i would rather have gas from the north
sea it's a more honest approach and it
improves our energy security so i don't
agree with uh with chidi on that but
what i do agree is that ultimately we
need to get rid of gas but in the
meantime we have to be franker with
people that is a necessary transition to
get to net zero and i would just point
out to him too is that 1.5 is absolutely
the aim but the paris agreement was
always for two degrees and it's good
that we've increased that ambition and
this is only going to go in one
direction which is more ambition more
innovation and lower carbon emissions we
have to make sure we keep the energy
flowing in the meantime we've only got
about 20 seconds chilly but i want you
to to give you get your chance to come
back at that
asserting that gas is a transitional
fuel is a bit like showing up at an a
meeting and congratulating people being
off the whiskey and handing them a huge
crate of wine and congratulating them
no gas is not a transition fuel
okay i think we can say you'll have to
agree to disagree for tonight um no
doubt we will revisit this issue another
time but chidi oti obihara and ambi
amber rudd thank you both very much
indeed for your time tonight
thank you
and that's everything from us for today
on tomorrow's show i'll be joined by
climate justice activist days ajahi and
bruce niles director of climate
imperative thanks for watching i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you